what's going on guys this is rob and we
just crossed 2 million subscribers but
before we talk about that you're
probably wondering what this green
screen is for
well i'll explain that later on in the
video for right now i want to talk to
you guys
about crossing 2 million subscribers
this has been one hell of a journey man
it's been one
crazy journey you know one of the funny
things and one of the things you guys
commented on twitter this guy chris
actually his last name starts with an m
but i don't want to dox him so i'm not
going to dump his whole name
but i remember chris he's been around my
channel for a long
long long long time i will probably
never forget chris but one of the cool
things
is that he was talking about how he was
here back when i was doing like the
parking garage vlogs and all that kind
of stuff right those you guys
who were og double og you guys remember
that the parking garage vlogs back when
i first started my channel uh back when
back when i first started this thing it
was it was crazy see at the time
there weren't really a lot of comic book
youtube channels you had like
a handful of channels but there wasn't
really anybody who was making like 30
minute long videos
explaining comic book characters or
teams and showing like scrolling comic
book panels and different things like
that it's so exciting
to see the community grow the way that
it has and it's so exciting to know
that that well i wouldn't necessarily
say i was a pioneer of it
that i've contributed to it and so you
know i really want to say thank you guys
i really want to say thank you guys for
for helping this channel grow
to 2 million subscribers you know it's
just it's nuts when i think about it you
know it's crazy when i think i've been
doing this for like seven or eight years
right and i've met
so many of you guys you know i will say
that's been the greatest part of being a
comic book youtuber
is meeting you guys and stuff like that
i miss i miss going to comic-cons and
hanging out with you guys
i miss going to comic-cons and buying
you guys comic books
right hearing what kind of stories you
all love i i miss that i miss that
so much it almost brings a tear to my
eye man because
that that i would say was probably the
single greatest experience that i had
in being a comic book youtuber was going
to come about conventions and just
meeting you all right there were there
were some of you guys and
and it's it's still a little weird to me
but there were some of you guys i would
be
in i'd be in like a lane right you guys
know how comic-con's work you have the
huge aisles all kind of stuff you got
artist alley all kinds of you guys would
come over from two lanes away
hey rob i heard your voice and i'm like
what they're like yeah
i would recognize your voice anywhere
and i thought it was you you know and it
was it was cool right there were some of
you guys who were really socially
awkward so you had a really difficult
time navigating like social situations i
was like no
they ain't gonna fly i'd snatch you up
and bring you into the group and be like
hey everybody this is such and such
you're gonna come off that social
awkwardness you hang out with me that
ain't gonna fly man like i'll have you
talking to people
i will have you socializing with folks
but it's stuff like that right i just i
miss hanging out and talking to you guys
so so much right it was one of the
coolest things so
having said that what's the whole idea
behind this here behind me okay so
one of the things you guys don't know a
lot of you guys don't know is that i
have a whole nother youtube channel
and it's about to hit a hundred thousand
subscribers i wanted to grow it
without advertising it on comics
explained one to see if it could be done
and two
to make sure that i actually had a
vested interest in it because one of the
things that i've learned is not to
advertise a channel here on comics
explain
if it's something that i'm not actually
seriously huge into
because what i end up doing is losing
credibility because i basically send you
guys to a dead youtube channel
so this other youtube channel is called
geek culture explained and basically
it's the film and tv side of comics
explained at the moment
so where we focus here on educating you
guys in terms of comic books
making you guys an expert on comics in
30 minutes or less covering stories
character explanations team explanations
over a geek culture explained
we focus on movies and we focus we'll
really have the room around us so it's
like a weekly news show
um and then we focus on like the tv
shows right so a lot of those videos are
a more stripped down explanation of what
you'll find here so
here like with kane the conqueror
appearing in loki really was a mortise
not necessarily kang but
a variant of king with that character
appearing at the end of loki as you guys
know i did two videos that were over 20
minutes one on kang and then one
on on immortus over there i'll do a
video that's like 10 minutes long and
i'll basically just give you the origins
and powers of the character we do
trailer reactions i break down trailers
and episodes right to explain stuff
that's going on in there so you guys
understand what's actually happening
that kind of thing right now the funny
thing about that is i want geek culture
explained
to be bigger than that i want it to be a
channel that focuses on like anime and
focuses on video games and basically
everything under the geek culture sphere
i want it to be huge
it's one of the things that i always
wished i'd done with comics explained
but by the time i realized
it was something that i wanted to do the
channel was already just kind of etched
in stone in terms of his form and
function
and there is such a thing as having your
channel niched down
so hard that it's actually really more
difficult
to grow it out of that than it is to
just launch something else and so
that's what we're doing here right we're
basically launching a whole other brand
uh that is a complement to comics
explained but it's actually to grow and
hopefully become bigger than comics
explained
both in terms of the channel's size as
well as the kind of content we're
covering so
if you guys are interested in that kind
of thing make sure you guys go over
there and be a part of it we just
finished our coverage on loki right now
we're covering some interim stuff until
we start getting
into the marvel what if series and then
we'll do a whole bunch of coverage on
marvel what if
all that kind of good stuff so make sure
you guys check out geek culture
explained please help that channel grow
in the same way you helped this one grow
and thank you guys for helping me reach
2 million subscribers again it's been
one hell of a journey
and i wouldn't trade it in for anything
i would go through all the
all the rough patches we had those of
you guys who've been around the channel
for a long time know
that we had some pretty big rough
patches uh i would do it all over again
right i would go through all those rough
patches i would go through the burnout
the whole nine yards
i would do it all over again because
this has been one of the most rewarding
experiences of my entire life
so with that being said guys we're going
to bring this to an end thank you guys
for watching
make sure you check out geek culture
explained and i will catch you all later
peace